speaking of religion really unfortunate
story coming out of hollywood and
religion
it's about chris pratt
chris pratt is a movie star
probably the most popular movie star in
the world right now
he has become
a voice for christians
he's become a voice for maybe kind of
conservatives i don't know or at least
non-leftists
he did this because he was at an awards
show and he spoke about god and he said
god loves you there is a god god loves
you and you should have a relationship
with god something to that effect i'm
paraphrasing but that's what he said and
it was so refreshing to see because the
rest of hollywood usually in their
speeches insinuates there is a moloch
you should sacrifice to moloch you
should give your you should sell your
soul to the devil and they always say
the opposite of what chris pratt said so
it's very refreshing to see that now
chris pratt is coming out he's saying
i'm not a religious person
and it's this it's being reported in a
lot of places but it's a very long
interview in men's health and
uh
chris says look i'm i'm not really a
religious person i i think religion has
been oppressive af
for a long time i don't know how i be
came to be viewed as this voice of
religion people said that i went to
hillsong church which i guess is not
down with the rainbow they're not the
most lgbt church in the world and i've
never been to hillsong church and it was
it was just
really sort of sad to see again it's
such a long interview i can't even find
the exact quote it's fine though it
doesn't really matter what the exact
quote is it was just really really sad
to see it was
like in the old days of the
house uh
committee on un-american activities
and hollywood black listing the
hollywood people would be asked are you
now or have you ever been a member of
the communist party
which i firmly defend by the way i'm
perfectly fine blacklisting communists
because communists are very bad and
we're subverting our country
now we've got the opposite now we're
having are you now or have you ever been
a christian and chris pratt doesn't
disavow god entirely here he but he
basically says i'm spiritual but not
religious it's really really weak sauce
and i think it's it's dumb for him to do
it
because he's trying to thread this
needle and remain a big hollywood star
in the mainstream but not not get
cancelled but not totally throw away his
beliefs and it's just not
not going to work man i mean i think
this is
this is kind of what
in the gospels you see spoken of and
what the early christians saw
at a certain point
you're gonna have to pick a side okay if
you if you believe in god if you
believe in the truth and you say true
things and you stand up for the truth
people are going to hate you for it and
then you're gonna have to make a
decision do you go with the mob or do
you stick with the truth and do you
stick with god and right now
chris is trying to stand in the middle
and he's trying to he's trying to
thread that needle and have have
everything you you can't you can't do
that
you can't have everything and if the
choices are between
picking the
absolute degenerates in hollywood and
fame which even for a giant star like
chris pratt will be fleeting or the
truth and god and what is right it
shouldn't be a hard decision i know that
it is in the moment but it should not be
a hard decision and there's a kind of
humility with pratt saying wait why am i
i'm just some big dumb movie star why am
i why are you having me be the voice of
religion and theology and faith in
america but
that role has been thrust on him to some
degree and he should he should step up
to it that's sad it was a disappointing
interview and i hope he doesn't do it
again and i i don't want to be too hard
on him but come on man toughen up
toughen up man what are you doing
the institutional power is with the libs
okay the the people are with chris pratt
here the people are with god the people
are with beautiful places the people are
with normal ways of life the people are
with don't trans the kids the people are
with don't kill babies the people are
with all the normal stuff and yet the
institutional power is all on the
opposite side of that the the
institutional power
is pushing extremely fringe views such
as
transiting the kids
it's because the
principalities and powers and
dominations of this world are on the
side of the ruler of this world who is
the devil okay the prince of this world
but but i i don't think that speaks for
the majority of people or our best
inclinations and so
this is where you get populism from
especially the populism of the last few
years
how is it that the people seem normal
but the elites are so crooked and and
wicked and
stupid and evil well that's sort of the
way it's always been
and so you've got to kind of pick aside
right now go to rockauto.com enter
knowles in there how did you hear about
us box the value of your minivan your
pickup your sedan whatever you drive
probably appreciated pretty
significantly last year so take care of
your automotive investment and keep more
of your money by buying the auto parts
that you need to maintain and repair
your vehicle at rockauto.com
they have got the auto parts you need
they will give you a selection of
trusted name brands to choose from and
incredibly easy to navigate website
buddy of mine i mentioned this a week or
so ago buddy of mine goes to the brick
and mortar auto port store
he made a mistake he apologized he knew
it was dumb to do that he goes to the
store he tries to get a part for his car
that he wanted right away
they wanted to charge him 400 he says
wait a second i know rockauto.com has
been sponsoring the michael knowles show
for years let me go check out their very
easy catalog oh here's the same part the
exact same part for 150
so what are you doing you guys this is
highway rivalry here at this brick and
mortar shop don't make his mistake go
straight to rockauto.com for your auto
parts write knowles in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
i'm so glad that you like that clip now
hold up before you go anywhere before
you go anywhere wait wait wait wait no
wait hold on wait
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications get all of the new videos
that come out here we're closing in on a
million subscribers do it i want i want
to get there i want that i want that big
trophy i want to make sure that we can
spread truth before youtube completely
shuts us down so text email carrier
pigeon this youtube channel to your
friends we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you